everything we've been doing so far has
involved systems of equations in this
video we're gonna tackle the problem of
systems of linear inequalities linear
inequalities what we're going to do is
essentially figure out all of the points
on the XY plane that satisfy a system of
linear inequalities so let's start with
our first linear inequality let's say we
have 2x minus 3y is less than or equal
to 21 and we've seen how to graph this
before you can just graph this line and
then figure out what the less than part
means so let's just rearrange this into
slope intercept form so if you subtract
2x from both sides minus 2x minus 2x
subtract 2x from both sides we get
negative 3y these cancel out is less
than or equal to 21 minus 2x or we could
say negative 2x plus 21 and then we can
divide both sides by negative 3 and
remember when you divide by a negative
number you multiply by a negative number
you swap the inequality so you get
negative 3y over negative 3 is greater
than or equal to negative 2 over
negative 3x plus 21 over negative 3 and
so this equation becomes y is greater
than or equal to two-thirds X minus 7 so
that's this first inequality right there
let's graph it I'll graph it in orange
y-intercept is negative 7 so 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 and it's slope is positive 2/3 so when
you run 3 you go up 2 when you run 3 you
go up 2 when you run 3 you go up 2 and
in this direction if you go back 3 you
go down 2 so the line will look
something like this
the line will look
like that keep going and since we have y
is greater than or equal to essentially
this line the area that satisfies this
inequality is going to be above the line
at any point for any X for any X you
pick this is the value two-thirds X
minus seven so if Y is going to be
greater that it'll be all the points
above that so just this constraint right
here Y is greater than two-thirds X
minus seven or this constraint which is
the same thing two X minus three Y is
less than or equal to 21 will give you
all of this area up here I don't want to
draw it too dark just yet so we'll give
you all of this area all the way above
this line now let's add another
inequality to the mix let me do that
other inequality in blue let's say I
have X plus 4y let's make it less than
six so the problem I have written here
as less than or equal to but I want to
mix it up with a couple of a couple of
with an equal sign and a couple of them
with without an equal sign just so we
remember how to graph these things and
so let's put this again into slope
intercept form so we can subtract X from
both sides then the left-hand side just
becomes 4y the right-hand side becomes
negative X plus 6 and then we can divide
both sides by 4 divide both sides by 4
and we get Y is less than negative 1/4 X
plus 6 so just like the first equation
let's graph the line the gridline is
well the y-intercept is positive 6 so
one two three four five six and then the
slope is negative 1/4 so every time we
run by four one two three four we're
gonna go down one so you run by four one
two three four you go down one you run
by four one two three four you're gonna
go down one so this line is actually
going off the table if you go back by
four one two three four you gonna go up
by one and since we're not actually
including the line we're gonna have to
draw a dotted line
here so it's gonna be a dotted line draw
my best try my best to draw a dotted
line and actually let me continue that
previous line there cuz I actually want
to show where they intersect it goes a
little bit off of our graph paper but
the graph of this equation is that right
that I did a dotted line because it's
not less than or equal to it's just less
than so this inequality if I were to
graph it it would be the area below the
line it would be the area below the area
below the line right there that's what
satisfies this inequality for any X this
is the value of that line but the Y's
that satisfy it are the Y's that are
below the line now if I were to ask you
if I were to have a system where I have
2x minus 3y is less than or equal to 21
and another equation or inequality I
should say these aren't equations these
are inequalities they're not equal to
each other
the other one is X plus 4y is less than
6 and if I were to ask you what X's and
Y's satisfy both of these inequalities
well you say well gee it's just going to
be the overlap of their solution sets
right it's going to be the area in the
XY plane that satisfies both of them so
in this case it'll be the part that's
above the orange line remember I shaded
that in orange right there the part
that's above the orange line that's that
right there so all of this above the
orange line and the part that's below
the blue line and the part that overlaps
that satisfies both of these I'll do it
in yellow maybe I'll do it in yellow the
part that satisfies both of these is
right in between right in between the
lines there
now what if just for fun we were to add
a third equation let's add a third
equation in green 3x plus y is greater
than or equal to negative 4 well it's
the same drill we put this in a slope
intercept form so you get Y is greater
than or equal to negative 3x minus 4 I
just subtracted 3x from both sides we
can graph this line its y-intercept is 1
2 3 negative 4 it has a slope
of negative three so every time you go
one to the right you go down three one
two three if you go one to the left if
you go negative one in the X direction
you go up three so you go negative 1 1 2
3 negative 1 1 2 3 negative 1 1 2 3 so
this line right here this line right
there it's going to look like this
it's going to look like that trying my
best to draw it that's that right there
and I can have it in bold I don't have
to do a dotted line because I have a
greater than or equal to and so what are
all the Y's that are greater than this
line well for any x value you pick for
any x value pick the value of negative 3
X plus negative 3 X minus 4 is going to
be this and we care about the Y values
that are greater than that so it'll be
above the line so for just this
inequality will be everything above the
line and then if someone were to come
along and say all right tell me show me
graph me all of the points on the XY
plane that satisfy this system of
inequalities what would you tell them
well it would be the overlap of their
solution sets so the part of the XY
plane that exists in all of their
solution sets so it's above the orange
line right we have to be above the
orange line right and we graph that
before it was all in in orange before
because we're above the line 2 X 2/3 X
minus 7 it might trick a little bit
because it has a less than here but when
you put it in the slope-intercept form
you know for greater than so it's
everything above this line which was all
of that over there everything below this
line below the blue line and not
including the blue line and everything
above the green line so it's going to be
this area right over here is the
solution set and we're going to include
this boundary right here and we're going
to include that boundary right there and
since I engineered the problem to have a
less than there not a less than or equal
to up here is going to be a dotted line
because you're not actually going to
include that line anyway hopefully you
found that useful